اسمحلي ابدا برساله لعبد الاله المالكي
وبعدها رساله رساله من الدوسري يا مالكي
ستيفن جيرارد ضيع لقب الدوري الانجليزي
الغائب كان منذ 25 سنه تقريبا على ليفربول
لانه تعرقل بلحظه وخسر الكره وذهبت لدين
بابا وسجل هدف
الفوز لتشيلسي في تلك المباراه التاريخيه
المعروفه عام 2014 لهيك مش لازم تزعل مش
لازم تتحمل مسؤوليه الخساره لانه لا
تتحملها اكيد وحدك هاي الامور بتصير بعالم
كره القدم وارجو من الجمهور السعودي انه
ما يحط الضغط على عبد الاله المالكي اللي
قدم مباراه جيده جدا ان كان اليوم امام
المنتخب البولندي او ان كان امام المنتخب
الارجنتيني هذا حال كره القدم فيها اخطاء
في لحظات ما بيكون اللاعب فيها موفق بيخسر
كره امام المرمى بضيع ركله جزاء هذه
الامور طبيعيه
وبما انه حكينا على ركلات جزاء فخلينا
نروح لسالم الدوسري سالم الدوسري ايضا
اعيد نفس الكلام
هناك الكثير من اللاعبين الكبار عبر
التاريخ اللي اضاعه ركلات جزاء وهذا بعرف
انه صار كلشي هذا الكلام ولكن يجب ان يبقى
دائما بدهن سالم الدوسري لان المنتخب
السعودي بحاجته وسالم اليوم كان افضل لاعب
برايي الشخصي في هذه المباراه على المستوى
الفردي على مستوى خلق الفرس على مستوى
الثنائيات اللي كان ناجح انه يفوز فيها
لذلك مش لازم تزعل يا سالم نهائيا ولا
لازم اي حدا من الجمهور السعودي يفرض اي
ضغط على سالم الدوسري بسبب اهداف ركله
الجزاء لانه هي امور بتصير مثل ما حكينا
بعلم كره القدم وامور طبيعيه جدا
وبما انه عم نحكي على ركله الجزاء فخلينا
ايضا نحكي عن القدر بلحظه انه يوجه سالم
الدوسري نحو الجهه اللي لازم يسدد فيها
وراح على نفس الجهه وصد الكره وايضا تصدى
بعد ذلك لتسديده اللي كانت همم بعد ذلك
مباشره على الكره الثانيه وكان ناجح جدا
اليوم في ايقاف المنتخب السعودي وبكل
امانه المنتخب السعودي اليوم كالعبي يلعب
ضد تشيزني يعني بمنتخب بولندا كان متفوق
في كل شيء
هجوميا في خط المنتصف نعم دفاعيا اليوم
المنتخب السعودي لم يكن بقوه مباراه
الارجنتين ولكن خلينا نحكي بصراحه وببوضوح
اكثر شويه عندي علامه استفهام على سبب
الاستحواذ الزائد بالكره من جانب المنتخب
السعودي كان بيسوى بمرحله من مراحل
المباراه تتسلم الكره للمنتخب الكولندي
خليه يستلم كره ويسيطر عليها وارجاعه دافع
العاب بدفاع عميق رجع دفاعك لوراء دافع
بشكل جيد وترك الكره للمنتخب الهولندي ولو
لمده 15 دقيقه قبل المباراه خليه يسيطر
على الكره الكره
تتخلى عن الكره شويه تسمح للمنتخب
الهولندي سيطر على الكره شويه لحتى يفتح
لها مناطق تستفزه اكثر ليطلع من ويفتح
مناطق بالخلف ينجح المنتخب السعودي بتسجيل
هدف التعادل او ربما كان هدف الفوز اا
منها اليوم منتخب السعوديه معتمد على مصر
تسلل معتمد على الدفاع المتقدم كثيرا
كالعب يلعب بضغطه متوسط ولكن كان في كره
ايضا لليفاندوفسكي كان عم يحاول يطبق فيها
المنتخب السعودي ومسابقه التسلل وما نجحت
معه اليوم دفاعيا المنتخب ما كان بشكل
اللي كان فيه مباراه الارجنتين علي
البليهي بدا المباراه بشكل جيد جدا ولكن
بعد ذلك كان في اكثر من خطا ارتكبه واحده
من هاي الاخطاء تسببت بالهدف الثاني الاول
عفوا ولكن لا باس هي اخطاء بتصير بالعالم
كره القدم هذه الامور بتصير بعلم كره
القدم هذا لا يمنع انه بصراحه نتيجه
المباراه لا تعبر باي شكل من الاشكال عن
طريقه سيرها بكل امانه المنتخب البولندي
كان اليوم اكثر ذكاء من المنتخب السعودي
افضل بكل شيء ولكن المنتخب البولندي كان
اذكى
رجع لمناطقوا سكر المساحات على المنتخب
السعودي رغم كل ذلك المنتخب السعودي كان
قادر يوصل الى مرمى المنتخب البولندي
ويصنع ما يقارب 14 او 15 فرصه في هذه
المباراه ويسدد 15 تسديده على المرمى ولكن
بالمرصاد للاسف الشديد كان في سوء تركيز
من جانب لاعبين المنتخب السعودي هذا امر
ايضا اكثر بشكل كبير على نتيجه هذه
المباراه اهدار فرص سهله ساندحه للتسجيل
يعني هاي امور كمان بتصير بعالم كره القدم
في مباراه ما بتكون موفق فيها ولكن براي
الشخصي السبب الرئيسي للخساره هو اول شيء
هدف منتخب بولندا وتوقيت هدف منتخب بولندا
اللي جاب دقيقه 40 تقريبا هذا توقيت صعب
جدا انك تتعامل معه ولكن رغم ذلك المنتخب
السعودي رجع بالمباراه وتحصل على ركله
جزاء توقيت اهداف ركله الجزاء كان اصعب من
توقيت هدف هولندا ايضا وبالتالي هذا الامر
اكثر بشكل اكبر على اداء المنتخب السعودي
في شوط المباراه الثاني رغم ذلك السعوديه
حاولت السعوديه حددت مرمى بولندا بولندا
همم باكثر من مره باكثر من كره باكثر من
فرصه ولكن مثل ما حكينا هو التوفيق اليوم
ما كان حليف المنتخب السعودي نقطه اخرى
ايضا تبديلات ايرفيرينار برايي الشخصي
كانت ممتاز جدا هل في اي شيء ممكن لهم في
في على المدرب الفرنسي في هذه المباراه لا
اعتقد ذلك ما في اي يوم على ايرفيرينار في
هذه المباراه الا انه فكره الاستحواذ
المبالغ في على الكره مثل ما حكينا ببدايه
كلامنا همم غير هيك تبديلات كانت ممتازه
جدا بالوقت الصحيح 100% بين الشوطين قرر
يغير مركز سعود عبد الحميد ويحطه ك- ظهيره
ايسر ويغير مركز بريك ويحطه ظهير ايمن بعد
ذلك طلع البريك ونزل سلطان الغنام سلطان
الغنام اللي اعطى زخم هجومي اكبر للمنتخب
السعودي بالشوط الثاني على الجهه اليمنى
لانه بيكون امانه بشاط المباراه الاول
المنتخب السعوديه كان بيهاجم فقط من الجهه
اليسرى من الجهه اليمنى ما شفنا اي كره
تقريبا في شوط المباراه الاول من المنتخب
السعودي سعود عبد الحميد كان جيد بالمساند
الهجوميه نعم ولكن لمسه الاخيره او
التمريره الاخيره العرضيه كانت دائما تروح
للمدافعين منتخب بولندا وهون ايضا في عتب
على لاعبي الوسط اللي ما كانوا عم بيعطوا
الكثافه الهجوميه اللازمه بعمليه التواجد
داخل منطقه الجزاء لما يكون في هجمه عن
طريق احد الاظهره او احد الاطراف ولكن رغم
ذلك المنتخب السعودي مثل ما حكينا نجح
بتشكيل الخطوره عن الجهه اليمنى بعد دخول
سلطان الغنام وسعر المنتخب السعودي اخطر
على الجهه اليمنى منه على الجهه اليسرى
اعجبني ايضا
باخراج العبد الاله المالكي راسا بعد ما
سبب بالهدف وهذا ليسما على المالكي من جان
برونار ولكن لا هو خاف عليه من خطا اخر
بيكون اللاعب بمرحله انعدام ثقه بالنفس
وبالتالي ممكن هذا الشيء يتسبب انه يرتك
اخطاء اخرى ويزيد الضغط عليه لذلك قرر
يحميه طلعوا نزل اللاعب اخر بداله
تبديلاته كانت حاميه بالميه براي الشخصي
حتى محمد البريك لما شاف انه الجهه اليمين
مش فعاله طلع البريك ونزل سلطان الغنام
مثل ما حكينا هجوميا المنتخب السعودي كان
يفتقد اليوم لتحركات صالح الشهري بالشكل
اللازم صالح الشهري لم يكن بمستوى
المباراه الاولى اليوم ولكن رغم ذلك قدم
مستوى مقبول الى حد ما البريكان همم
وسانته الدفاعيه في هذه المباراه بالشوط
الاول كانت ممتاز ولكن بالشوط الثاني شوي
قلت مسانده الدفاعيه وهو هجوميه لم يكن
قادرا على تشكيل الخطوره ولكن بشكل عام
كان مستوى ايضا مقبول سالم الدوسري كان
رائع خصوصا في شوط المباراه الاول كان
رائع سالم الدوسري كلام اخر يعني اثبت
المنتخب السعودي اليوم ان الفوز على
الارجنتين لم يكن محضر المصادفه لم ياتي
بالصدفه لا نهائيا كان فوز يستحق المنتخب
السعودي كان فوز يستحق ان يحقق لاعبي
المنتخب السعودي واليوم لولا الحظ لولا
بعض التفاصيل البسيطه في هذه المباراه لك
مباراه ايضا انتهت لصالح المنتخب السعودي
ولكن دائما نقول لما يكون في عندك فريق
كبير بالمجموعه مش اصعب مباراه هي اللي
بتكون ضد هذا الفريق اصعب مباراه بتكون ضد
الفرق اللي ما بتكون حاسب الحساب مثل
المنتخب البولندي اليوم على كل حال الان
السعوديه بثلاثه بثلاث نقاط بولندا باربع
نقاط السعوديه عندهم مباراه مع المكسيك
بالجوله الاخيره اذا حققت فيها الفوز هي
متاهله بغض النظر عن اي شيء لذلك همم يجب
على المنتخب السعودي انه يحاول تحقيق
الفوز بتلك المباراه لا يضمن التاهل حتى
لو مش اول مجموعه مش مشكله ولكن قد يتاهل
اول مجموعه ايضا ما صار شيء همم براي شخص
يجب على جمهور السعودي انه يكون فخور فخور
باداء فريق اليوم فخور بالمستوى اللي
قدموا اجبر في بولندا على ان الدافع 90
دقيقه بمهاجميها بسلانسكي ليفاندوفسكي
بملك غيرهم من اللاعبين بكتشفياك بغيرهم
بكاش اللي كان يستحق طرد بالمناسبه في شوط
المباراه الاول ولكن الحكم ربما يعني شاف
انه لا لقطه ما فيها طرد وهاي وهاي قرارات
تحكيميه لا يجب ان يتدخل فيها احد ولكن
بكل الاحوال اليوم المنتخب السعودي مثل ما
حكينا كان يلعب ضد تشيزني وصارت الاخطاء
الفرديه البسيطه جدا اللي كلفته الخساره
في هذه المباراه وهي امور بتصير بعلم كره
القدم والبطولات الكبرى تلعب على التفاصيل
لذلك انا متاكد انه ايرفر النار في
المباراه القادمه راح يتفادها هذه الاخطاء
وراح يركز على انه اداء الفردي يكون افضل
على المستوى الدفاعي في المباراه القادمه
بالتوفيق للمنتخب السعودي مبروك عشاق
المنتخب البولندي وسنرى ما سيحدث بعد قليل
في مباراه المكسيك والارجنتين الى ذلك
الحين